the russia ukraine crisis is causing
uncertainty in natural gas markets as
western countries weigh potential
sanctions against moscow the future of
nordstrom 2 the russian-built pipeline
in the baltic sea has been brought into
question when it comes to nordstrom 2
the pipeline that would bring natural
gas from russia to germany if russia
further invades ukraine it will not
happen but in europe the picture is more
complicated that's because about 40
percent of the continent's gas imports
used to generate power for heating
cooling and for some industrial
processes come from russia europe
absolutely has huge interdependence
with russia on gas and it really is an
interdependence the pipeline is awaiting
approval to operate from german and eu
regulators if granted it will double the
capacity of an existing pipeline in the
region people are saying you've got the
north stream one link why do you need a
nordstrom 2 a second link in the eyes of
critics will increase
the dependence of germany and europe on
russian energy exports concerns that
supplies to europe will be affected by
the tensions come as european and asian
prices for the commodity soared amid
winter supply shortages so how does the
rising demand and tensions in the region
have rippling effects on the global
market including on u.s efforts to plug
the supply gap
officials in the biden trump and obama
administrations have opposed nordstrom 2
over fears that it would enhance
moscow's political sway in europe we
don't want europe's energy supplies to
be dependent on vladimir putin now fresh
threats from the u.s to halt the
765-mile long underwater system are
underway as russia amasses troops and
weapons on ukraine's border and as
geopolitical tensions are increasing
around ukraine
uh russia invaded ukraine already once
in 2014 annexed part of his territory
the crimean peninsula
sanctions were placed on moscow from
western countries including germany
following that military action but the
financial penalties didn't include gas
now the united states are saying that
this time around we should we should
push for broader sanctions if russia
attacks ukraine again and we should
include energy
so
essentially the pipeline is in the
middle of all this
russia has been pushing for the pipeline
to be approved as gas in europe has been
in short supply that's partly because
gazprom moscow's state-run supplier
refilled domestic inventories and
allowed its sizeable storage in europe
to run unusually low president vladimir
putin said quick approval of the
nordstrom 2 pipeline would help
rebalance the european market those
comments exacerbated hawkish fears that
moscow might be weaponizing energy a
limited supply of russian gas in europe
has added to the global demand for gas
and specifically gas
liquefied natural gas that can be
shipped from other places so the
liquefying natural gas facilities in the
u.s just going at full tilt to try and
meet as much of that demand as they
could
u.s gas prices have risen because more
gas is being exported but the total
production of all existing facilities
can only export a maximum of around 12
percent the rest is sold at home keeping
u.s prices mostly insulated from
international ones
any u.s sanctions targeting natural gas
in russia could come at a cost for
europe which may struggle to find quick
alternatives of the supply
however those penalties are unlikely to
be put in place by president biden more
likely that they will reach some sort of
compromise
and the germans are saying look if there
is a russian aggression in ukraine if
the russians march in again
into their
neighboring country then we will stop
the pipeline